my name is
I'm a buffalo herder and my family
inherited this profession from our
ancestors we're nomadic but we have been
living in this area for 12 years
before the drought our areas used to be
Lush with fish and livestock but it's
been worsenic for the last three years
we can't take it anymore our livestock
has perished fish have died and so have
birds all because of the water shortage
in the marshlands
we have to buy water to keep our buffalo
alive
we also have to buy father to feed them
because there is no grass anymore but in
many cases our buffalo die because they
drink the remaining water in the marshes
which is contaminated or our animals
become trapped in the mud
um
I have lost 25 Buffalo this season if
this continues I will have to sell all
of them and change jobs but where should
I go from here